it's a narrative so unnerving ly
repetitive it's become familiar in the
US this week our nation was shot and
horrified when a gunman opened fire as I
was leaving the gym someone warned me
not to go outside if there's a man with
a gun
the gunman the number of casualties the
location that may all change but one
thing remains the same the perpetrator
in a mass shooting is almost always a
man Emma Mayen this is a j+ and this
Sunday we are on a trip to find out why
so many men are mass shooters what other
commonalities they have and what we can
do to prevent it and on my worst day I
could beat the hell out of you I don't
think so
the answer to why so many mass shooters
in the u.s. are men may have something
to do with this cowboy
well not exactly this cowboy it's more
about his image and what he represents
manhood we are headed right now to
Stanford University to meet up with
Marci Bianco so she can tell us about
why there's this disparity between men
and women when it comes to mass
shootings
I see the origins of mass shootings to
be a combination of the American sense
of masculinity and the idea of the
American man and the myths of American
manhood I think the American cowboy is
one of the great American myths and that
is someone who loves freedom who seeks
exploration and and who feels very
entitled to that freedom men account for
a little less than 50 percent of the
u.s. population and yet they're the
majority of perpetrators in u.s. mass
shootings the uncle says the gender
disparity might be explained by the way
the u.s. perceives and markets guns guns
themselves actually have been given a
gender how do you represent yourself as
powerful as virile as aggressive as
strong you you own a gun
Bianca says US culture is defining
masculinity by its lack of proximity to
femininity and that might be one reason
why we're not seeing as many female mass
shooter
it's not biological but it is very much
cultural guns are cultured or kind of
codified to be men's toys like if you go
into a toy store guns are not and the
girl I'll write guns are in the boys
aisle and this difference doesn't mean
women are any less capable of violent
acts women and men are actually equally
violent they're not women aren't any
less violent men but they use less
lethal type means usually and it's not
just gender most mass shooters have in
common
another overlooked threat is a history
of domestic violence
Omar Mateen the deadly shooter in US
history who killed 49 people at pulse
nightclub in Orlando Florida he had a
history of it
so did San Bernardino school shooter
Cedric Anderson who killed his wife that
had a history of domestic violence
allegation and James T Hodgkinson who
was seen assaulting his daughter then
there's Robert Lewis dear and some we
Cho and the list goes on if a man feels
that he can physically and emotionally
harm his intimate partner and that is
okay then of course he can go on to the
street and do what he wants to to a
larger community because no one will
criminalize him were penalize him for
doing so and if domestic violence is a
common thread among us mass shooters
Bianco says misogyny is often
intertwined because of how the culture
defines manhood Elliot Rodger killed six
people after posting rants online about
women rejecting him romantically and
then he used that rejection as fuel for
his murderous acts girls are not
sexually attracted to me there's a major
problem with that
major problem that's a problem that I
intend to rectify and that type of
distorted logic is common among mass
shooters according to miscarry this idea
that shooters are psychotic is just
wrong it's all about perception they
know what they're doing they know what
they're doing is wrong they feel
justified in doing it
because of their fantasy and their
perception that these people have
wronged them and therefore they feel
right in what they're doing so even with
all this information about manhood
misogyny and domestic violence as common
characteristics if we wanted to sketch
out a likely profile of a mass shooter
we couldn't and that's because the
catalyst for each man is different
prevention is difficult this is not
something you could say well we think we
could stop this tomorrow these are not
people who just snap these are planned
and they can be extremely well-planned
the planning depends upon the person
mascara says there are two types of
gunman one will target anyone and
another will look for specific victims
but both of them have distorted vision
so gender a distorted perception a
history of domestic violence and
misogyny those are all common traits for
masked gunmen but there is one more
thing that u.s. mass shooters have in
common they're white 50 of the 90 mass
shooters since 1987 have been white
that's 55% which is intriguing because
the US census says 77 percent of the
nation is white and white men
specifically make up about 31% of the
population so why are they so
over-represented in mass shootings well
it all goes back to that cowboy so when
we think about gun culture in America
and its origin so profoundly located in
this sense of white America and America
as a white nation men who have through
the day that this country was founded as
an American nation have had full
freedoms and Liberty to act as they
would like to act
she says the definition of manhood in
the United States is directly tied to
heterosexual white male masculinity
white men historically in this country
have felt entirely
the certain ways of being and they've
seen the world changed and as a result
they feel defensive that they need to
take up guns take up arms and defend
themselves against changes in America on
the same day a white command named James
T Hodgkinson targeted a congressional
baseball game an Asian man named Jimmy
Lam killed three of his co-workers two
men two different races on opposite
sides of the country so what can we do
how can we fix this if we had a proper
gun reform gun legislation trail
legislation that actually prohibited
open carry that required background
checks I think in turn we would see a
kind of curbing of mass shootings in
America and we've seen this in other
countries Australia hasn't seen a mass
shooting in 20 years after enacting gun
legislation in 1996 Bianco says that the
United States needs gun legislation that
fits the 21st century and Miss Carrie
she says that when mass shootings happen
we shouldn't be focusing on the gunman
when these incidents happen just give
the facts and and focus on the victim so
there seem to be a lot of commonalities
between masked gunman in the u.s. what
do you guys think tell us in the
comments below don't forget to Like
share and subscribe and join us every
Sunday for your news in context